It is time for Drew's News.
Your good news mama bird feeding you that good news worm.
Okay, so you're one of my nearest and dearest
and we work alongside of each other every day.
When I just walked up to you,
it was like walking up to,
you know, I think your friends are your mirrors.
Yes.
And so what do you think?
Where is Drew Barrymore?
I know!
That's what I'd like to know.
You look, I mean, you always look amazing, but what?
What?
I feel like I look like J.Lo or something
and I don't think I could ever have said that in my life.
Well, 'cause you do look like J.Lo,
and you look like some glamazon alien beauty.
What happened?
Wow!
I know, isn't it crazy the power of hair,
makeup and wardrobe?
I am telling you what I love about Chris Appleton,
Charlotte Tilbury and Brandice Daniel,
what they have done is they're really well intended people
who want to show you what's possible visually,
but really take you through how you can feel good.
'Cause the better you feel,
the better you're going to not only behave,
but receive and just walk through life.
Like do whatever it takes to build that confidence
so you can go out there and conquer that day.
Yes.
(audience clapping)
Well, how come you get a big makeover
and I just look like Ross Mathews?
Like can I get a little, can I just try that hair on?
Yeah, here take some.
I have so much hair to spare.
Look, oh.
(audience clapping)
It's not bad, better on you.
Better on her.
Well, let's get to some news,
because, first up, we're traveling again.
I'm so proud to say and excited to announce
"The New York Times" reports that people
are taking trips inspired by their favorite TV shows.
People are flooding to Wyoming
to get a taste of "Yellowstone."
(audience clapping)
And I know my favorite show.
Some people are heading to the UK
to tour "Bridgerton" style castles and drink high tea.
And Scotland's tourism board even developed
a 12-day "Outlander" tour of Scotland,
complete with historic places,
palaces, fortresses, and gorgeous Highland views.
Do you have any of these destinations
you wanna go to because of TV shows?
Like I watch "Emily in Paris," so now I'm like obsessed.
I wanna just go spend time in Paris now
and wear beautiful clothes.
Well, I definitely don't wanna go
to "The Handmaid's Tale" place.
No, no.
What's that place called, other than hell?
I can't think of the name.
Gilead! I don't wanna go to Gilead.
No.
No, but I'll get back to you on that one.
I watched "House of Gucci" again.
House of va Gucci.
And I wanted two things, to go to Italy or Olive Garden.
That's where I wanted to go.
Anyway, yeah.
Well, next up, we all need to have a little bit of fun.
Remember fun, you guys, right?
I'm having it right now.
Me too.
But are you getting enough of something called Type II Fun?
Let me explain what this is.
"The Washington Post" reports Type II Fun
is actually something.
It's a term that comes from the climbing community,
like the mountain climbing community.
Oh, I'm so relieved.
Right?
'Cause it does sound like something scary, Type II Fun,
but it's good I think.
It can apply to all of us.
And they describe it as the kind of fun
that hurts a little bit.
So in terms of climbing,
this could mean like climbing up a mountain,
but doing it at winter or at night.
So it's fun, but it's extra challenging, okay.
And for the rest of us, here's some examples for us.
Like a New Year's polar bear dip.
You know, when you jump into an ice cold lake?
Or eating like a hot pepper contest,
like that hurts, but it's.
Yeah, these are all such common examples.
I'll give you two, birth and tattoos.
Those are fun.
Everybody's doing it.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
They're painful, and yet it hasn't stopped anybody.
I've also been to a happy hour that hurt the next day.
Yeah, exactly.
Hangovers, birthing and tattoos.
Think about it.
Yeah.
No, just good, old fashioned Type I Fun for me.
You know, I don't need danger.
Okay, well, next up, "People" reports someone called 911
when they saw this big boy on a rooftop in Pennsylvania.
Firefighters arrived.
What? Oh my God.
The dog casually turned around and walked back
through a balcony door into the apartment.
It turns out he just likes to sunbathe.
He's a real life Snoopy.
Oh my God.
So that's it, that's the story.
Like the dog is not in trouble.
The dog just likes to kick it up there like Snoopy.
Do you know what that dog's favorite word is?
Roof.
(Drew laughing)
(audience clapping)
I thought you were gonna say
the dog's favorite word is Type II Fun.
(upbeat music)